هل تصف ما تراه
من حيث الإصابات بأنه جرائم
ضد الإنسانية أه بالنسبة لي أستطيع أن أقول
ذلك بالتأكيد أقصد ماذا ماذا
كيف تفسر هل تعرف
ملعب الناس أو الأطفال يلعبون في
الملعب أو البقاء في المدرسة  أو أه
تعلمين يتعالجون في المستشفيات
فيقتلون أو أو ينامون في
منازلهم ويقتلون
بلا سبب يعني بالنسبة لي لا أرى
أي سبب ولكن من وجهة نظري أه على
الأقل كوزارة  الصحة
لا أنا من
حق المريض أن يعيش من
حق المريض أن يحصل على فرصة للحصول على
العلاج كيف ترى
مريض مصاب بالسرطان وعمره 5 سنوات
أو ست سنوات ولا يتلقى
العلاج الكيميائي أه فيه  أربعة أسابيع أو خمسة
أسابيع ماذا تفعل ماذا تفعل كيف تسمي ذلك كيف تسمي
هذا الحادث كيف
تسميه كيف
تعرف أن هناك طفل حديث الولادة يحتاج إلى
أجهزة تهوية وانقطعت عنها
الكهرباء وهم  نفاد الغاز ونفاد
الدواء
وأخبروني أنهم يحاولون وضع ثلاثة
نيوات في حاضنة واحدة، هل تصدق
ذلك وأرسلوا لي صورًا لذلك
لأنه ليس لديهم أي شيء آخر
يفعلونه، لذا وضعوا  أطفال ثلاثة منهم في
حاضنة واحدة لأنه ليس لديهم
الكثير من مصدر الطاقة لدعمهم
وعلى الرغم من أنهم بدأوا في
فقدان هؤلاء الأطفال حديثي الولادة ويريدون
إخراجهم كيف تسمي ذلك كيف
تسمي ذلك مع  الأطفال
من مستشفى ألفا ما هو الجدول الزمني
من حيث إدخالهم إلى مصر ومن
يملي هذا الجدول الزمني وكيف
يمكنك التدخل للأسف هذا
ليس في أيدينا أعني كما أخبرتك أن
سيارة الإسعاف لدينا الآن كما نتحدث تنتظر
في الحدود جاهزون لنقلهم على
الفور حتى المستشفيات التي سيتم تجهيزها
بأجهزة التنفس الصناعي والحاضنات
لهذا الغرض جاهزة لذلك
نحتاج فقط إلى الجانب الآخر لإحضارهم والأهم من ذلك
أننا جاهزون لاستقبال
10 ضرب 20 ضرب 30  أكثر من ذلك بكثير
نحن على استعداد للقيام بذلك، أعني أننا
موجودون في 37 مستشفى منزليًا، وقد
حددنا أكثر من 11000 سرير وأكثر من
1700 وحدة مركزية أكثر من آه، كما تعلمون، هناك 150
سيارة إسعاف جاهزة لنقل آه هؤلاء
المرضى لذلك قررنا أن نكرس جهودنا
وننشرهم  أكثر من 38.000 طبيب
و25.000 ممرض وممرض جاهزين
للعمل، لذا مهما كانت الأرقام التي
سنحصل عليها، فسنتعامل مع
لماذا لا تحصل على هذه الأرقام
لأنه يمكنك التعامل مع
عدد أكبر من المصابين؟  لن
تحصل عليهم مرة أخرى، الأمر
ليس قرار مصر، قرار مصر
هو
لا أعرف، لكن بالتأكيد هناك
شخص يجب عليه التحقق
ويجب عليه الإخلاء وإعطاء التصريح
لهؤلاء المرضى للخروج من هذه
الأراضي إلى  إلى الجانب المصري ولكني
أخبرتك أن فريقي وطاقمي
يبقون ليلًا ونهارًا في انتظار
دخول كل حالة لبدء التعامل
معهم، هل تعتقد أن إسرائيل لها
الكلمة الأخيرة بشأن المرضى الذين يخرجون
ليس لدي معلومات لأقولها  بخصوص
هذا لا أستطيع أن أقول شيئًا
لا أستطيع أن أكون متأكدًا منه ولكن بالتأكيد هناك
أه سلطات معينة على
الجانب الآخر لاتخاذ القرارات بشأن من سيخرج
وإلا كان من الممكن أن ننتظر
قدوم آلاف المرضى لأنهم
لدينا
28000 مريض جاهز يمكننا أن نقول 10 20%
منهم يحتاجون إلى
تدخلات مكثفة لا
يملكونها